and god speak all these words saying
i am the law thy god which have brought thee out
of the land of egypt out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any driven
image or any likeness of anything that is
in heaven above or that is the earth beneath
all that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them for i the lord thy god am a
jealous god visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
ensuing mercy unto thousands of them that love
me and keep my commandments thou shalt not
take the name of the lord thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain remember
the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy work but
the seventh day is the sabbath of the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son nor thy daughter
thy man's servant nor thy midservant not thy
cattle nor thy stranger that is within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and earth the
sea and all that in them is and rested the seventh
day wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath day
and hallowed it honor thy father and thy mother
that thy days may be long upon the land which
the lord thy god giveth thee thou shalt not kill
thou shalt not commit adultery thou shalt not
steal thou shalt not bear false witness against
thy neighbor thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant nor his maidservant nor his
ox nor his ass nor anything that is thine is
god is good and all the
time happy sabbath everyone
thank you very much for coming to the house
of god to listen to his word it is my honor
it is my privilege it is my delightful
joy to stand before you to speak for god
i can think of no higher privilege other than
to reflect god in life than to speak for god
it's a very solemn responsibility and my
intention as best as my humanity will permit me
is to give you thus said the lord
prophets and kings page 6 26 paragraph one
elohim writes the words of the bible and the
bible alone should be heard from the pulpit
this is my intention my desire and by the
grace of god i will give you thus said the lord
and of course that inspired commentary from the
pen of ellen white the servant to this church
it is 21 minutes to 12. i am unfamiliar with
when you get out but i'll try to release you
as soon as i possibly can without rushing
the spirit of god is there anyone with us
today you are not a seventh that god bless
you thank you for coming are you together
may the lord bless your lives and guide you right
into his kingdom when he comes please keep coming
to worship with us until that happy day when
i look at you again and i'll be looking at two
members of the seventh day adventist church can
you say amen say it again anybody else you are not
a seventh-day adventist nice your hand ah i see a
hand moving in the pull in the balcony god bless
you thanks for waving your hand i have picked
you out may the lord bless your life may the
lord grant you the desires of your heart with such
abundance that his goodness to you will move you
to serve him with all your heart and soul thank
you very much worship with us again any one of us
you are not okay thank you my lovely sister let
me take a chance what's your name say langley
okay all right all right well
god knows exactly what it is
thank you very much for coming and may lord place
a hand of mercy on your life and never remove it
say amen for our sister anyone
else you're not a seventh
well move the hand so i can like that
oh there you are what's your name
what's your name
actually god bless your life god bless your
family and god bless you so torrentially
that you will be a blessing to others say
amen for ashley anyone else and i'm not
joking these are prayers i'm praying for
our guests this is no joke anybody else
okay
did i miss someone where oh hi i see those
two hands thank you for coming is this your
first time you're visiting with us in the
balcony say something what did the person say
yes we don't want it to be the last if
you have a need may the lord supply it
if you have a sickness may the
lord remove it and if you have any
thanks for coming and god bless
you in every possible way say amen
did you raise your hand sister
or you were saying amen okay it's uh 19 minutes to
12 and temperance and all things including sermons
before i go any further let me ask you to do three
favors for me favor number one if you have a bible
and the form i prefer that you use
this over there this is the holy bible
this is not the holy iphone are you with
me no i'm quite serious this does not ring
this has no temptation to check whatsapp
instagram the fiber email facebook
whatever else occupies our time this comes loaded
with temptations i was in a hotel room a few
years ago preparing to go speak downstairs
and i was reading the bible on this thing
and these smartphones they have while you're
reading or doing whatever you're doing
an app or something popped up at the bottom of
an advertisement and he said hey are you lonely
no that's what it said it was an advertisement for
dating asian women i was in the room by myself all
i needed to do was take the tip of one finger and
touch it on all the information would have come
to the preacher reading the word of
god what i'm saying to you is this
this does not
it has all the power of the universe
so if you can use one of these
do that if all you saddled with is this then
please don't let it ring in the presence of a
holy god and under no circumstances walk
out of the church to answer the phone
unless you're the physician to the president
of the country and he needs your services
other than that respect the god of heaven
and earth if that's reasonable say amen
the second favor i ask very polite believe me
while i'm speaking all i want you to say is lord
put your words in that man's mouth jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth the lord said unto
me behold i have put my words in thy mouth
i only want to speak god's words i will
surely be tempted to speak mine but my has no
my words have no saving value but the words of
god jesus said they are spirit and they are life
so ask god to put his words in my mouth and
favor number three i want you to think as you
listen isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason together
set the lord think as you listen and don't chat
don't do anything to offend the spirit of
god and that also may disturb me let's pray
father in heaven thank you for
allowing me to live to see this day
hearing to listen to your people saying i
thank you for vision to see them and to see
the sunlight and the grass i saw this morning and
the guinea fowl i saw running across the meadow
i thank you today god for sanity thank
you for the knowledge of jesus christ
one verse says he hath not dealt with
us after our sins not rewarded us
according to our iniquities dear god thank you
for not giving me the full punishment i deserve
ah god if i have a friend did you forgive me you
know i'm weak i am dirty i am clay i ask you now
lord through the agency of your spirit take
full possession of my mind my mouth my heart
so that i am simply an instrument in your hand
and let the tune you play is the tune of truth
father bless all those who have come and a
god i ask you to pour out a special blessing
on the visitors touch let this day long remain
in their minds now god bless not only us
but wherever your people are worshiping you on
this holy day your bible sabbath bless them god
bless this country and every country represented
by this congregation let the leaders always
remember in all the deliberations righteousness
exalted the nation and by the way father remind us
exalteth an individual i commit this message
to your glory day god suppress self i pray in
jesus name let god's people say amen and amen our
subject holy for god our theme is holy for christ
you